John Carpenter's 1988 opus they live is
a scathing indictment of capitalism and
the culture of greed masquerading as a
b-movie about invading aliens it stars
professional wrestler rowdy roddy piper
as a homeless labourer whose world is
turned upside down when he finds a box
of special sunglasses that allow the
wearer to see the truth about subliminal
messaging forcing humanity to obey it's
one of carpenters greatest films but
grab a pair of hoffmann lenses for
yourself to see the truth that even
hardcore fans may not know about they
live HP lovecraft array nelson and
richard armitage sharp-eyed viewers may
have noticed that the screenplay is
credited to Frank Armitage which happens
to be the same name as Keith David's
character this of course as a pseudonym
carpenter wrote the screenplay but felt
it was strong enough of a collaborative
effort with his future wife sandy king
and roddy piper as well that he didn't
take sole credits instead he lifted the
name Armitage from the Dunwich horror a
classic story by HP Lovecraft whose work
often involved characters being driven
mad by discovering hidden truths
Lovecraft wasn't the direct inspiration
for they lived though instead carpenter
drew from another short story ray
Nelson's eight o'clock in the morning
published in 1963 and turned into a
comic book in 1986 it features a
character named nada who awakens to the
fact that the world is secretly being
run by snake-like aliens who control
humanity's thoughts and actions more
many of the stories elements would later
make it to the screen
carpenter wisely added a few tweaks to
the plot and changed a few elements to
make it more believable or at least as
believable as a story about Magic
sunglasses that let you see aliens can
be I've given you a choice either put on
these glasses or start eating that trash
the man with no name like the lead
character of Nelson's short story Roddy
Piper's character is called nada because
he is meant to be a blank slate everyman
he has given very little backstory and
has never referred to by his name in the
film even once with nada only appearing
in the credits in the year since though
Carpenter has let it slip that the
characters first name is John and that
he indeed has an extensive backstory
even if the filmmaker himself doesn't
know what it is
couple of days in an interview carpenter
revealed the only one man knew not his
full origin story Roddy Piper before
filming carpenter asked Piper to come up
with a backstory on his own and further
told him to never share what it was with
the director to lend his character more
authenticity
true to his word Piper never went on the
record before his untimely death in 2015
meaning that nada will always be what
carpenter intended a mystery to everyone
even the man who wrote and directed the
movie the most brutal brawl in cinema
history and nearly six minutes long that
the iconic alleyway fight between nada
and Frank is one of the most celebrated
brawls in film history it's been
endlessly referenced quoted and parodied
and this inevitably brought up as a
point of comparison every time new
contender for the best fight scene of
all time emerges with the idea of
creating a fight scene that would be
completely unique in films Carpenter
turned to stunt coordinator Jeff Amada
whose work can be seen in action movies
like Lethal Weapon The Bourne Ultimatum
and Furious 7 and to piper drawing on
his experience as a professional
wrestler the result speaks for itself
but David complimented Piper on helping
to make the film more realistic while
Piper's assessment of David makes it
clear that he's no slouch either he's
all out of bubblegum
soon after not as and pleasant discovery
about the world around him he has a
scuffle with a pair of cops and manages
to get away with one of their shotguns
by ducking into a building which turns
out to be a bank as the patrons reactant
Arda with the shades and shotgun he
utters one of the all-time classic
badass lines and cinema history here to
chew bubblegum and kick ass
and I'm all out of bubble the line has
been embedded in pop culture ever since
but it wasn't carpenters creation it
came directly from Piper
according to carpenter Piper carried a
book full of one-liners that had used in
his wrestling promos and while he was
writing the script Carpenter lifted the
best one for the scene it's just a shame
he never got to use that one on Hulk
Hogan sticking it to Reagan carpenters
choice to make his heroes
down-on-their-luck homeless men up
against alien invaders who all seemed to
be rich yuppies and more frightening Lee
politicians underlines the film's
ultimate message which should be even
clearer today than it was 30 years ago
Carpenter has gone as far as calling it
a documentary about the exploitation of
the poor by the upper-class and an
indictment of the rampant economic
inequality that makes it possible and
even film the opening in an actual
homeless settlement paying the residents
as extras if carpenter intended they
lived to be a ballistic missile lobbed
at 80s materialism and excess he's never
been shy about who he saw as the
ultimate symbol of that access President
Ronald Reagan speaking of Starlog around
the time of the film's release Carpenter
was clear on this point calling the
president and his cabinet a bunch of
crooks in the year since carpenter has
been happy to elaborate on his contempt
for Reagan whenever given the
opportunity in an interview with the Los
Angeles Times in 2013 carpenter said
that he'd decided I had to make a
statement and that's they live fighting
the literal and figurative way that it
was given the finger to Reagan when
nobody else would